In this video, we'll solve our
simple example in LibreOffice.
Go ahead and open
the spreadsheet,
IMRT_SimpleExample.
At the top of the spreadsheet,
you should see our data.
For each beamlet
and each voxel, we
have the dose that
that beamlet gives
to that voxel at unit intensity.
So we have this data for voxel
one, voxel two, voxel three,
all the way up to voxel nine.
Each row corresponds to
one of the six beamlets.
This is the data that
we saw on the slides
in the previous video.
Below the data, we've outlined
our decision variables,
which are the intensities
of the beamlets.
So for beamlets one through six,
we have one decision variable.
These six decision variables
are outlined in yellow.
Right now, the
decision variable cells
are blank, because the values
will be filled in by Solver.
Below the decision variables,
we have our objective.
Our objective is to minimize the
total dose to healthy tissue.
The healthy-tissue voxels are
voxels one, three, five, six,
and nine.
So let's go ahead and build
our objective in the blue cell
here.
So first, we want to
add up the total dose
that each beamlet
gives to voxel one.
So here we'll use
the function that we
used in the previous
lecture, sumproduct.
So type an equals sign,
and then sumproduct,
and select all of the decision
variables, semicolon, and then
all of the doses.
This will add up the total
dose that beamlet one gives
to voxel one, plus the
total dose beamlet two
gives to voxel one,
plus the total dose
beamlet three gives
to voxel one, etc.
Now we want to repeat this
for voxels three, five, six,
and nine-- the other
healthy-tissue voxels.
So go ahead and
type a plus sign,
and then sumproduct, again,
the six decision variables,
semicolon, and this time, select
the dose data for voxel three.
Now let's repeat this again,
but this time for voxel five.
So sumproduct, and
then the decision
variables, and the dose
data for voxel five.
Now for voxel six, sumproduct,
the decision variables,
semicolon, and the dose
data for voxel six.
And lastly, we're going to add
the sumproduct of the decision
variables, semicolon, and then
scroll over to voxel nine,
and select the dose
data for voxel nine.
Close the parentheses,
and hit Enter.
You should see that the
objective has a 0 right now,
because none of our
decision-variable values
are filled in.
When Solver fills in
our decision variables,
our objective
value will be here.
Below the objective
is our constraints.
The first four constraints
make sure that each voxel
of the tumor is getting
a dose of at least 7.
The last constraint makes
sure that the spinal cord
receives a dose
of no more than 5.
Let's go ahead and
construct our constraints.
For the first four
constraints, the left-hand side
is going to be the total dose
that that voxel of the tumor
gets.
So for voxel two, we
have the left-hand side
is equal to the
sumproduct of the decision
variables, semicolon, and
then the data for voxel two.
Close the parentheses,
and hit Enter.
We want to make sure
that this value is
greater than or equal to 7.
Now let's repeat
this for voxel four.
So equals sumproduct,
and then, in parentheses,
select the decision
variables, semicolon,
and the data for voxel four.
Again, we also want this one to
be greater than or equal to 7.
Now let's repeat
this for voxel seven.
So sumproduct of the decision
variables, semicolon, and then
the data for voxel seven, again,
greater than or equal to 7.
And lastly, for voxel eight,
we want the sumproduct
of the decision variables,
and the data for voxel eight
this time to also be
greater than or equal to 7.
And our last constraint,
we want to make sure
that the total
dose to voxel five,
the spinal cord
voxel-- so sumproduct
of the decision variables, and
then the data for voxel five,
is less than or equal to 5.
The remaining
constraints we have
are the non-negativity
constraints,
which we'll add in
directly in the Solver.
So now go ahead and go to the
Tools menu, and select Solver.
The Solver window should pop up.
First we need to tell Solver
what our objective is.
So go ahead and delete
what's in "Target cell",
and making sure that your
cursor is in "Target cell",
select the blue objective cell.
Now, we want to change "Maximum"
to "Minimum", because we're
trying to minimize the total
dose to healthy tissue,
and our decision variables
should be the six yellow cells.
Now let's add in
our constraints.
So in the first
"Cell reference" box,
let's select the first
four constraints.
Because they're all greater
than or equal to constraints,
we can add them in together.
And change the "Operator"
to greater than or equal to,
and then in "Value", select
the four right-hand sides.
Now let's add in the
spinal-cord constraint.
So in the next "Cell
reference" box,
select the spinal
cord left-hand side,
make sure that
"Operator" is less than
or equal to, and in
the second "Value" box,
select the spinal
cord, right-hand side.
Now let's add our
non-negativity constraints.
So in the "Cell reference", just
directly pick the six decision
variables, and make
sure the "Operator"
is greater than or equal to, and
the "Value" should just be 0.
Now, in the Options,
make sure you've
selected the Linear
Solver, and click OK.
Now go ahead and hit Solve.
You should see a
solving result that
says: "Solving
successfully finished.
Result: 22.75".
That's the optimal
objective function value.
Go ahead and select Keep Result.
Now let's take a
look at our solution.
So the optimal
solution is to have
beamlet one at an
intensity 2.25,
beamlet two at an
intensity of 0,
beamlet three at
an intensity of 3,
beamlet four at an
intensity of 3.5,
beamlet five at an
intensity of 2.5,
and beamlet six at
an intensity of 0.
This makes sense,
because beamlet two goes
across the spinal cord,
and beamlet six only
goes down healthy-tissue voxels.
And if we look at
our constraints,
we can double-check that each
tumor voxel is receiving a dose
of at least 7 -- one tumor
voxel gets a dose of 8 --
and the spinal cord is
receiving a dose of 5,
which is the maximum
possible dose.
In the next video, we'll see
an example of a real problem,
and how big the problem is
on an actual tumor case.